Speaker 1: Every central claim about the 2020
election made by failed former President Donald
Trump and the people around him, including
people like Mark Meadows, but also wackier
people like Sidney Powell, Mike Pillow, Lindell
and others. Every single one of those claims was
systematically contradicted and debunked by mostly
Republican testimony, as we saw during yesterday's
second day of the Trump riot hearings. I'm going
to give you some examples here, and you will see
how comprehensively every single
one of these claims is easily,
easily, easily refuted. Former Philadelphia
city commissioner Al Schmitt, a Republican,
said there is no evidence of even eight dead
people voting. Never mind the 8000 dead voters
that Trump and people around him claimed in.
Speaker 3: The claim that dead people were
voting. In fact, Mr. Giuliani told
Pennsylvania state legislators
that 8000 dead people voted in Pennsylvania.
You investigated those claims of voter fraud.
Can you tell us what you found?
Speaker 2: Not only was there not
evidence of 8000 dead voters voting in
Pennsylvania, there wasn't evidence of eight.
We took seriously every case that was
referred to us, no matter how fantastical,
no matter how absurd, and took every
one of those seriously, including these.
Speaker 1: So it's not that they say,
well, you have to investigate all of it.
It was investigated. You just don't like the
outcome of that investigation. And we've so dead
voters. That's one bucket of claims. We've looked
into it extensively. There was an investigation,
I believe it was in Michigan, where they started
with a list of I believe it was 10,000 supposedly
dead voters. And again, I now I believe it was
the Guardian, if not the BBC, they said, let's
randomly choose I think it was 35 of the thousand
or to 2000, whatever. Let's investigate them. And
then with those 35, they found most of them.
There was evidence that the people were alive.
Like there was just really no reason to think that
they were dead. In a few cases, it was people who
were indeed alive at the time that they voted and
then they when they mailed in their ballot, then
they died. Nothing illegal there. In some cases,
there was like junior senior confusion. I mean, it
was all it was all just picked apart. Next claim,
Georgia smuggled ballots. Former acting deputy
attorney general testifies that he personally
investigated the Georgia smuggled ballots,
found nothing, told him it was false,
but it didn't matter who play again.
Speaker 3: A testimony from Mr. Donoghue, who
appeared before the committee before today.
Mr. Donohue, you we talked so much about
whether or not the White House and the
president was informed about the interim
report on the results of the investigations,
the interviews that have gone on on Fulton County.
How would those results have been communicated
to the White House, to the president?
Speaker 2: I don't know how they were
initially communicated. I do know that they came
up in subsequent conversations with the president
and that rose and I essentially told them
we looked into that and it's just not true.
Speaker 3: Okay. So he was I informed.
Speaker 2: I told the president myself
that several times in several conversations that
these allegations about ballots being smuggled in,
in a suitcase and run through the
machine several times, it was not
true that we looked at we looked at the video,
interviewed the witnesses. That was not true.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: We're doing
a class action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: So there is another claim, the idea of
ballots smuggled in. And there were videos with
ominous music of suitcases in different places
with no reason whatsoever to believe that the
suitcases contained fraudulent ballots. People
have suitcases. It's not like a huge smoking gun
in and of itself. And Trump was told, and yet he
continued to repeat it. And then lastly, again,
just as another example, we could do this all day,
but I won't do it to you. The other claim was more
votes than voters in Philadelphia. Philadelphia
and Pennsylvania in general became a big focus
because they stopped counting and then started
again. Of course, if you understand the scheduling
for vote counting in Philadelphia, you would know
that they just have a schedule. They stop counting
and then they start again the next morning. Not
really evidence of anything, but the other claim
was more votes than voters. And William Barr,
Trump's own attorney general, says it's not true.
There were not more votes than voters and anybody
just Googling Philadelphia Pennsylvania
population would be able to realize that.
Speaker 3: I to turn to President Trump's
false allegations about election integrity
in Philadelphia. The attorney general
discussed these allegations at some length.
Speaker 2: You know, the idea the president has
repeatedly suggested that there was some kind
of outpouring of unexpected votes in inner city
areas like Philadelphia as recently as January
13th when he walked off the NPR said. He was asked
by the interviewer, What's, you know, what's your
evidence of fraud? And he said, more people
voted in Philadelphia than there were voters.
And that was absolute rubbish. Right. The turnout
in Philadelphia was in line with the state's
turnout. And in fact, it was not is as impressive
as many suburban counties. And there was nothing
strange about the Philadelphia turnout. It wasn't
like it was all these unexpected votes that came
out of the Philadelphia show. Right. You know,
I think once you actually look at the votes and
there's an obvious explanation. He you know,
for example, in Pennsylvania, Trump ran
weaker than the Republican ticket. Generally,
he ran weaker than two of the state can.
Speaker 1: Anyway, the point is, William
Barr knows that it was all B.S. So every
single one of these claims, what do we know
about them? We know two important things. One,
there was not actually any evidence for
them, but maybe even more importantly, two,
there were Republicans around Trump who knew
the claims were B.S. and would tell Trump that
they were B.S. and it did not matter. So a very
critical moment in yesterday's Trump riot hearings